the finale of Monarch Legacy of monsters
brings human scale drama to a Titanic
monster story and succeeds way more than
you may have expected here's how this
chapter of the Monarch story wraps up
Monarch covers a lot of ground in its
first season but the story starts with a
focus on Kate Randa and canaro Randa
searching for their father Hiroshi after
discovering that he had two separate
families in Tokyo and San Francisco the
newly discovered half siblings set out
with former Monarch member Lee Shaw and
love interest May to find him in the
past we see how a young Lee Bill Randa
and kir founded Monarch and how KO
vanished in a tragic Hollow Earth portal
investigation that tragedy informs
everything that follows Bill and Lee's
respective obsessions hiroshi's orphaned
upbringing and the modern state of
Monarch in the next to last episode of
the Season May K and leer pulled down
into a Midway point between the Surface
in the hollow Earth known as axis Mundy
there Kate discovers Koo still alive and
well believing that she had been in the
wilderness for about 2 months due to the
time dilation effects of the portals
she's oblivious that more than 50 years
have passed and that she's missed what
would have been most of her life
the reunion between KO and Lee and the
Monarch season 1 finale is heartbreaking
Kate refrains from telling her
grandmother her true identity or how
much time is passed but it all comes out
when they run into May and Lee hid him
behind a tree to conceal his aged face
Lee explains through tears the tragedy
they've both fallen into Koo breaks down
as well but she quickly accepts the
truth fortunately the group is able to
devise a plan of Escape Koo was already
using Lee's old Titan signal device to
send a message to the surface together
they carry it to the old pod he used in
1962 to travel to axis Mundy himself
they hook the device up and get it going
hoping that a Titan will open up the
portal above them and carry them home
but when the nearest Titan ends up being
both much closer and more aggressive
than anticipated things start to go
South Lee leaves the Pod to fix the
signal by hand only to be caught in the
crossfire when Godzilla appears amidst
the Titan duel he activates the device
again the pot is pulled into the portal
and Lee chases after it but he isn't
fast enough in a tragic mirror of koo's
1959 disappearance he lets go of her
hand happy in a sacrifice after finally
being able to keep his promise and and
bring her home while May Kate Lee and KO
fight to escape from axis Mundy canaro
is left on the surface to pick up the
pieces he gets kicked out of Monarch
after his leg heals and is told to go
back to his old life accepting that his
friends and family are dead but after
returning to Tokyo he bumps into his
father the man he's been searching for
since the beginning of the show your
reunion doesn't exactly go great Garo
berates Hiroshi for being a liar and an
absent father but it isn't that tell he
says that Kate is dead that his father
truly hears him roshi breaks down
devastated that his efforts to keep his
children out of his business only led to
their endangerment when Tim shows up
with evidence of Kate's survival though
Father and Son agree to work together to
bring her home we learn in the final
moments of season 1 that they end up
working with Apex the same Shady Tech
corporation that will later create meca
Godzilla and endanger the planet Kate KO
and may emerged two years after the
incident in Kazakhstan only to find
themselves in an apex facility on Skull
Island as Kong Roars in the distance
May's old boss Brenda Holland emerges
from the Shadows it seems that Monarch's
repeated inaction prompted some incling
including Tim to leave the organization
and join Apex this sets up the company's
immense Global power at the beginning of
Godzilla versus Kong at the core of
Monarch Legacy of monsters are a couple
of different love stories and they come
to the surface in the season 1 finale
down in axis Monday Lee reunites with
his belov Koo but it's 50 years too
late
ko ko is that really you of course it is
he's so grieved by the time he's lost
and ashamed of his old face said he's
scared to even look at her when they
meet at the same time May and Kate find
each other brought Closer by yet another
wild adventure their feelings for each
other have grown mutual and strong back
on the surface Hoshi faces the
consequences of his lies and infidelity
karo's mother emo makes it clear that
she no longer wants anything to do with
him but she emphasizes that he must
maintain a relationship with her son we
also learn that Hiroshi is finalizing a
divorce with Kate's Mother Caroline in
San Francisco were scientific
discoveries worth all the betrayals he
made along the way looking at his face
it's hard to imagine he answer yes like
his parents and Lee before him Hiroshi
fell into the Trap of obsession always
assuming he'd have more time at least
for him he still has a chance to make
things right with his children and show
how much he's always loved them Monarch
seems to say that it's easy to put off
the things that matter in life our work
our trauma and at times our own
self-loathing all work to keep us away
from the relationships that make life
worth living Lee returns from his first
axis Monday Venture and Vines the world
has passed him by out of guilt for
losing KO and shame for missing Bill's
death he believes he deserves the
imprisonment Monarch sentences into
meanwhile Hoshi has every opportunity to
be present for his families and tell
them the truth but he avoids doing so
perhaps he thinks himself Unworthy of
forgiveness or happy life as we're told
in one of the flashback scenes of
episode
9 it's a fact that's shown repeatedly
throughout season 1 when K realizes that
she too has lost so much time she
Grieves the life she might have lived
she Grieves her son's childhood and
youngest adulthood the death of Bill and
the many others she knew who lived and
died in the 57 days she's been in axis
mondy for her the choice would have been
easy she would have given up all her
scientific Adventures if it meant being
there with Hoshi as he grew up as Lee
tells her the world has changed but not
so dramatically people are still the
same and it's the people who matter
family secrets can do more than cause
divisions in some cases unresolved
issues can cause generational trauma
leaving people decades down the line to
pick up the pieces koob Bill and Lee's
obsession with their investigations left
Hoshi without a family when it came time
for him to build a family of his own he
was scared the same thing would happen
again you can read his double life as a
kind of desperate safety net if anything
were to happen to one family at least he
wouldn't lose everything or maybe it's
the opposite maybe he stayed distant
from everyone because he feared the pain
of losing them which is why he was never
around for long the final scene of
Monarch season 1 brings all of this
complicated history to Bear after
escaping axis Munday Kate finally
reunites with her father whom she's been
searching for the entire show he finally
uses his brilliant mind to help his
family rather than distance himself from
them when he sees his mother alive and
well looking exactly as she did when he
was a boy he collapses into her arms KO
had no control over the harm she
indirectly brought on her son but it's
still enlightening to see how her return
washes away Decades of pain it's as if
all of the baggage her Roi has been
carrying around with him suddenly fell
from his shoulders in that moment life
doesn't have to be painful anymore
healing can finally begin in addition to
the human themes of family grief and
regret Monarch Legacy of Monsters has a
larger message about the natural world
on our relationship to it the Titans may
be fictional but they still represent
the planet it's a world that humans have
assumed dominion over but which is far
stranger and more awe inspiring than
most can accept Kaiju have always been
metaphors for the environment in cinema
they show what happens when we destroy
it or pollute it with war they embody
the response of Nature's
self-preservation instinct to heal and
rebuild that metaphor has been present
in the monsterverse since the starts but
it feels more impactful in Monarch when
Kate Lee KO and may are stranded on axis
Munday they can't help but acknowledge
their powerlessness they feel out of
place knowing that this isn't a world
built for them the world isn't the thing
humans can ever truly control Monarch
seems to say we are a piece of it to no
more the Power hungry maneuvers of Apex
cybernetics stand in opposition to this
idea the company represents Mankind's
urge to subdue and assimilate nature and
its robotic advancements eventually
challenged the natural order itself in
Godzilla versus Kong leading to
widespread destruction and death Lea
gets a pretty complete Arc and Monarch
he begins as a cocky sexist American
Soldier meets KO and overcomes his
biases he starts to believe in the
mission of protecting the innocent but
experiences great loss in the process he
lives decades in shame and guilt and
then finally has a chance to make some
of his mistakes right when he forces KO
to let him go so she can escape back to
the surface at the end of season 1 he's
almost
laughing what are you doing my job what
are you doing back even 60 years later
he hasn't forgotten his promise to keep
her safe Le is happy to make the
sacrifice but that doesn't mean he's
dead if KO could survive in Access Mundy
for so long he might still be alive we
know that years of surface time are just
a matter of days in Access Munday so we
wouldn't need to hold out long before
rescue might come maybe by the time he
gets back Koo will have grown old and
the story will give them a long awaited
happily ever after the other big
question at the end of Monarch season 1
is about axis Monday itself we're told
by KO that it isn't truly the hollow
Earth but rather a middle point between
the realm of the Titans and the surface
but how does that work exactly in
Godzilla versus Kong a team of Monarch
and Apex operatives follow Kong down a
portal into the hollow Earth but they
don't get a chance to linger in the
strange lightning Forest the natural
answer is simply that the portal Network
beneath the earth's crust is far more
complicated than we previously thought
it's not just a subway line between the
Surface and the hollow Earth but a
confusing web of everchanging tunnels
with multiple exit points Kiko notes
that the ecosystem of axis Mundy is a
blend of surface flora and Hollow Earth
life since it seems easier to access
from both places that makes sense I
don't think this is a realm of the
Titans at all it's a place between
places it's also worth noting that axis
Mundy has some key characteristics that
separate it from the hollow Earth as far
as we know there's no temporal
Distortion in the hollow Earth as the
humans in Godzilla versus Kong Journey
between the two Realms in one to one
time also the gravity inversion of the
hollow Earth the aspect of the realm
that prohibits humans from reaching it
for so long doesn't exist in axis Mundy
for now there are still a lot of
questions about how these different
places connect and relate to one another
with luck Monarch will get a season 2 to
explore those ideas further forok
Creator Matt fraction the complex theme
of inheritance was a guiding principle
from the start fraction told Men's
Health there's a recurring theme in the
work I do that I like stories about
people deciding to accept their
inheritance or reject it children being
the parents of adults and all that kind
of stuff director Matt shakman echoed
the sentiment in an interview with the
Verge saying the project appealed to him
because it was a multigenerational
family story because monsterverse fans
know what happens later in the movies
the story of Monarch had to stay
grounded in the human characters in the
end that's what makes the emotional
payoffs of season 1 so so satisfying
thematically the show's creators were
also tuned into the historical
significance of Kaiju Cinema co-creator
Chris black told movie web Godzilla and
the Kaiju of the monster verse have
always been sort of existential
allegories for whatever the threat is
and then if you're looking at our Modern
Age I think you could pick obviously
climate change and global warming is a
very real and current issue Kurt Russell
was also interested in the project
because of its larger thematic
implications revealing to Entertainment
Tonight I was probably I don't know
maybe 8 years old when I first saw
Godzilla and that was an image that I
never forgot what I love about sci-fi is
great sci-fi as an opportunity to
examine some huge philosophical
[Music]
questions